now i'm certain that there are many folks sitting in the audience or thinking that
in the era of kaiti and by specifics and bella that you can give in the mountains of montana
what is the role of a gprc 5d targeting antibody drug conjugate so i'll steal the famous words for
new york fashion designer and say when it comes to myeloma more is more and less is a bore
i do have to back up my claim with some evidence and as you can see this slide is showing
all of the data that exists on the patient demographics the safety the efficacy of a
gprc 5d targeting antibody drug conjugate in the absence of data that is published
available in literature i will actually show you a real world patient one of mine
who loves to be on clinical trials so this is a standardized multiple myeloma patient
who gets diagnosed in 2015 uh received cybody for induction followed by transplant consolidation
land maintenance and relapses three years later the patient goes to multiple different
iterations of carfilisma-based therapy kd kpd dkd someone chose the courage to actually give him
data cypalm dex quadruplet and he is essentially refractory to all of these therapies the patient
eventually hops on to a clinical trial receives the calistomab and citrulumab achieves complete
remission within a month of therapy and within a month within a week of cr actually develops
grade 4 covid 19 infection okay patient comes off of trial and remains
under observation with multiple recurrent infections relapse is about four years
later goes on to another trial with aloe bcma CAR-T and relapses within six weeks so essentially
primary refractory to an aloe bcma car the patient does have a declining performance status with
weight loss what would you offer a patient like this who is primary refractory to a bcma car
who has had recurrent infection after one dose of teclismas in the past and who may not be very
interested in receiving telquetamab as next line of therapy so we have been talking about stepsisters
and uh stepchildren gprc5d is truly an orphan it's an orphan receptor it has no known ligand
and uh it has no known function uh for um myeloma cells as well as uh some of the epithelial cells
that is expressed we do know that it can easily be lost at the time of diagnosis uh even in
treatment naive patient in 10 percent of other times and patients who actually receive gprc5d
cardi or for that matter by specific nearly two-thirds of them can have loss of gprc5d
at a time of progression it has come a long way uh since his journey in 2001 in 2019 eddie smith at
msk she identified gprc5d as a myeloma-specific antigen simultaneous development of a homegrown
autologous CAR-T that showed promising efficacy with some cerebellar toxicity the concept was
taken up by a pharmaceutical company and now we have arlo cell which has shown promising efficacy
in patients who have a private bcma therapy again at the cost of some cerebellar toxicity gprc5d by
a specific antibody it'll quite a bit of time to get rid of it but if you're interested you can get
a map was approved by fda in 2013 as being utilized as well in this slide you can see that
a lot of the investment actually has been in the in the area of karate as well as bispecifics
and you only see one antibody drug conjugate at the very bottom that has been developed in china
uh lm305 is an antibody drug conjugate targeting gprc5d developed by lenovo medicine and it's
tested in relapse refractory myeloma patient the three prior lines of therapy we still haven't seen
data on this particular trial so we're not sure what's going to happen in the next couple of years
but we did see some preclinical studies as well as that led to the adoption of this particular
molecule by astra zeneca in the form of rebranding and azts0305 so why target gprc5d with an adc
because it's still retained after patients who have been exposed and treated with a bcma
directed antibody and cartes secondly you all know about uh the trojan horse effect of an
antibody drug conjugate i will not uh spend too much time on that why would we develop this because
it is a mechanism of action that is actually free of the t cell effect so if we have patients who
have exhausted t cell phenotype after receiving by specific antibodies uh who have perhaps lost
bcma or have down regulation of bcma after a kite maybe a good candidate for this kind of therapy
uh the preclinical studies that looked at the gprc5d adcs again this data came from china
looked at mice models with gprc5d with incremental doses of the lm035 and what
you saw is that at three milligram per kilogram there was complete remission seen in the myeloma my
models and then that led to the adoption of the lm305 by astrazeneca as azd305 monotherapy
this is actually a trial currently open for enrollment many sites many investigators here
have experience using this on clinical trials uh the trial criteria if you look at it relapsed
refractory myeloma three prior lines they could have had prior bcma carty or bispecifics but they
can't have any gprc 5d treatment with a biospecific or carty prior uh it's a phase one slash two study
as a azd0305 is given as monotherapy every three weeks intravenously and the primary end points are
looking at safety and some secondary key elements are response rates as i'll speak and pds i do have
some experience with some trial patients on this particular with this particular product and i think
we have seen some modest efficacy what is interesting is that unless the unlike the mmaf
with mmae toxic payload we don't see ocular toxicities what you do see is some mild but not
you see otherwise with gprc 5d carty similarly they can have some cytopenias mild cytopenias and
skin rashes but none of the side effects that you see with talquitamab with dysgucia weight loss
and skin and oral changes in the last two minutes i'm going to briefly talk about why is there still
a role for in gprc 5d adc i think we briefly talked about this earlier as well that a carty
cell therapy is only available at major academic centers centers that have the ability to perform
for races and may not be available at the community sites it does require a carty a carty does require
patients to have a 24 7 caregiver some type of four week interval it does require time away from
work and home and uh family members there are bottlenecks with manufacturing time as well where
patients were rapidly progressing may not actually be able to wait four to six weeks to um actually
receive carty infusion and then we talked about the some of the late onset toxicities of carty
including neurological toxicities of parkinsonism and three percent uh non-elapse mortality of close
to 15 and secondary malignancies as well so they're all the problems with carty on the other
hand we have to be very careful about that and we have to be very careful about that in order to
do that we have to be very careful about that in order to do that we have to be very careful about
that in order to do that we have to be very careful about that in order to do that we have to be very
careful about that in order to do that we have to be very careful about that in order to do that we
have to be very careful about that in order to do that we have to be very careful about that in order
to do that we have to be very careful about that in order to do that we have to be very careful about
that in order to do that we have to be very careful about that in order to do that we have to be very
careful about that in order to do that we have to be very careful about that in order to do that we
academic site or a much larger committee practice you're not able to give a Bispecific to
these patients uh infections remain at risk even when you stop therapy you have published data now
that even when you stop all therapy with a Bispecific like the clistamab the risk
of hypogamma infection can persist not just for months but for years there's published data now
that even when you give to clistamab based therapy for six to nine months patients who relapse half
of them actually lose their bcmi either structurally or functionally and hence uh it's
not a viable option anymore for many of those patients uh and then in an era where we have
these problems with the bcma carti and by specific i think in adc the targets gprc5d is a very
exciting option and to go over the last few the last slide the conclusions i would say that the
ideal patients for a gprc5d adc would be the ones who are actually relapsing post-bcma therapy
whether it's a bispecific or carti which is what truly elderly and frail who are not able to
actually um undergo the process of the bcma therapy so i think it's a very exciting option
for many of those patients and then in an era where we have these problems with a bcma carti and
bispecific i think in adc the targets gprc5d is a very exciting option and to go over the last few the last like
undergo the process of carti cell infusion or for that matter having a recurrent infections
from Bispecific and very importantly patients who have limited access to care
i would argue patients still need to drive to the mountains of montana to get bella map and if they
have some degree of ocular toxicity and they're not able to drive an adc that targets gprc5d at
the cost of some mild neuropathy may be a very good option thank you
just in case there are any else fans in here i had a last slide that talked about there's a
about there's always room on the nice list.